Mr Rollins if you're thinking Easy Come
Easy
if you're thinking that Frank had
anything to do with coretta's death and
obviously you don't know very much about
him
Frank doesn't go around beating people
up he prefers to use a knife as this
weapon
and what do you prefer to use
as your weapon
why don't you search me and find out
Jennifer Beals in Denzel Washington in
1995's Devil in a Blue Dress based on
the acclaimed novel by Walter Mosley one
of America's best and most famous
novelists two years ago Mosley became
the first black author to receive the
national book Foundation medal for his
work now he's getting more attention
than he has in years for his latest book
called every man a king featuring an
ex-cop turned Detective Joe King Oliver
if you want to get rich you go into real
estate you don't write books and so I'm
not looking to get rich I'm just looking
to publish books and and to live a life
of you know of of satisfaction Walter
Mosley spent his early years in the
Watts neighborhood of Los Angeles the
only child of a black father and a white
Jewish mother they believed in
themselves and their rights in the world
and they believed in me and so that
allowed me you know to be somebody
regardless of any you know external
definition of who I was my parents gave
me a lot
Mosley tried political science and
computer programming but didn't start
publishing books until he was 34 years
old
he's turned out more than 60 cents
Beyond his calling card the Mysteries
Mosley's done non-fiction science
fiction graphic novels erotica and plays
plus television including snowfall you
tried to have him killed no gave me good
money to handle the job if you could I
left
but not before I kept my promise and the
Apple series the last days of Ptolemy
gray starring Samuel L Jackson based on
Mosley's 2010 novel because you went and
spent his money on impressing her I'm
celebrating her
it's been a while though since there's
been buzz like this there's more
attention being paid uh to this book
than I've had in a long time and there
are places like for instance to have
like a full page review also a cover a
page review on the New York Times book
review that's America's Nobel right
there you know I mean it's wonderful you
know and I never had it before
why do you think it's happening now
think that America is changing as far as
their appreciation of one of culture but
also of genre and of the meaning and the
strength of language Mosley's new book
Every Man a king follows the path of Joe
King Oliver as he looks into the case of
a man who may have been wrongly
imprisoned for me it's very different I
in most Mysteries I write you know my
black detectives don't want to get
anywhere near the police they work for
people who the police don't serve they
work against what the police are trying
to do but in this case I made him a
policeman because he was going to go to
prison and I want to say not only is he
black going to prison but he's a black
policeman going to prison so he has no
friends in there
he's trying to seek Justice
he's trying to see Justice by going to
Rikers to help a white nationalist
yeah which is
Rich well you know every in every novel
that's that's worth its salt is about
something other than the story something
other than the plot and in in this in
this book
it's about replacing hatred with love
racially are we in a better place in
America today than when you started
writing yes we are in a better place
today than we were
but
because we're coming closer together
there's a lot more friction
for Mosley the source of that friction
is simple
follow the money people of color are
more included than they ever have been
and part of that is because of the
amoral artificial intellect of
capitalism because they're saying we
have to do this because somebody writes
a black person writes a book and puts it
out there and then all these people buy
the book you know use mostly black
people and and capitalism said oh that's
a way to make money so we're going to
print more of those books
because we are a part of the economy we
are more included and that's you know
that's gotten better and part of it is
political but the but the people at the
top are not doing it because of morality
they're doing it because of money
nobody's doing it for Morality for the
past 14 years Mosley has made Brooklyn
his home Down Under The Manhattan Bridge
overpass you know when I'm in La I said
well this is LA or this is California
when I'm in New Orleans I said well this
is new Orleans in Louisiana but when I'm
in New York it feels like National
yeah it's like one great big old bear
hug
that's how I feel about it I like that
he writes every single day as soon as he
wakes up
365 days a year how long do you want to
write for
you mean in my life yeah I believe that
people should be able to retire
especially if they do something that
they hate you know or that that wears
them down but animals don't retire you
know and I'm an animal I I write I love
writing and I'm going to keep on writing
you know and you know I'm at some point
or another something might go wrong with
my head or I might be you know too tired
but right now I plan to write until I
can't write anymore
and people make a mistake of considering
mostly just a mystery writer he's a
novelist I mean there's so much more
love race money whatever he writes about
it's it's so much richer I mean there's
always this brisk plot to his books but
there's so much more to it and the sheer
enormity I mean he has such range and
what not only to your point what he's
written but the mass of books he's
written is incredible he's at a pace of
two a year now well and that passion for
it I didn't think about it until what he
said if you don't like it yeah you
should be able to retire but if you
don't live you love it keep doing it you
actually say if you if you hate it
so we'll work forever